hello freak [ __ ] I did I used to
[ __ ] used to do it a lot I'm sure
well I bet yeah here's the thing dude
like I at one point I was I was sort of
house-sitting for this this chick and
you know I humped a strange chick in her
bed and tied the rubber and a knot which
I would do you know didn't I rubber and
not threw it on the floor
her [ __ ] dog ate the rubber right and
like and and it was her boyfriends dog
and I'm thinking oh no the [ __ ] dog
maybe to throw up the rubber right like
it took the dog took the [ __ ] rubber
fur like a victory lap and it's gonna
drop and it's gonna look terrible for
this girl so I'm like following the dog
around ultimately the dog [ __ ] it out
and it was hilarious but I felt bad
cause like you know I base it's kind of
like sodomizing the doc right okay and
so then I felt like to make it up to the
dog you get the dog hi and when I owe I
owe it to the dog to do it myself and
like because this is a funny bit like to
swallow a condom for overload in it wow
that was part you got in my head I'm
gonna swallow a condom but then I was
like okay cool when I'm on to it when
I'm on tour in Europe
well I'll [ __ ] put weed in the condom
tie in a knot now it'll be like a skit
where um it's an international drug
smuggler skit I'll do ruin a country
I'll fly to the other country and [ __ ]
it out right and and I did it was his
[ __ ] saga I actually have a [ __ ]
epic like there's a huge like tent pull
a bit in my stand-up right now about
that whole I got arrested for
international drug smuggling and Sweden
um did you I did it was [ __ ] it's so
classic because of swallowing a carnival
greatest [ __ ] story ever did it's so
[ __ ] awesome yeah III get it
yeah how'd you get caught because I had
[ __ ] told the press like I was like
you know I just when I first said that I
did it was so but I did it so big they
want to try to [ __ ] swallow it got
stuck in my throat
yeah I'm sure I'm freaking the [ __ ] out
I'm turning you know like and then I'd
fly I fly from Norway to Sweden and
you know not so told me I was how big
was the nug dude I didn't even take I
didn't even break the buds off the stem
[Laughter]
in the same show mean your fingers how
big this thing was video and my next
comedy special it's on video
yeah they filmed everything it was
feminine form I didn't for my DVD is it
online I'm sure it probably is but
what's what's so I'm so excited about my
next comedy special is that so many of
the stories I tell them I stand up are
things that happened on camera
originally right so I'm editing into
editing into the [ __ ] actual stand-up
kind of like you do with the podcast
like supporting foot archival footage
right which just demonstrates that that
everything is not only not true let's
put it it's not only truthful it's not
even embellished that's like it's like a
hundred percent and so like I'm just so
excited to do that my god wait a minute
it's hard to tell because of the
perspective where's your fingers bad
it's play it so they could say it's whoa
no you can see four feet people that are
like it's like basically like a 1/8 it's
it's totally stuck inside of your body
up I was trying to swallow it I wouldn't
go down trying to barf it wouldn't go it
wouldn't come on No so I'd fly to
[ __ ] Sweden because like why my
buddies are like we got to take a [ __ ]
that out ever took six and a half days
I caught him not and Knox is like Davey
you're gonna dive intestinal
strangulation because this if I can
gonna block up my intestines oh my god
hey whatever like I'm sorry it took it
took days to come out and when it came
out man you must be exploded I don't
want to tell my jokes I'm okay Podcast
cuz that's [ __ ] lame Bose big
important part of the day there's
there's it's [ __ ] the best bit I love
it you know I'm proud of what I'm doing
on stage so you are you saying that pot
is okay that was how I got in that's how
I first did it then I realize okay
because if something wild boys every
time we would like I wouldn't freak the
[ __ ] out whenever we went to the Far
East cuz you know you're not gonna be
able to find weed and that's not okay so
I at any time I went to anywhere where I
wasn't coming confident I would be able
to get weed i sat there with my before
going to the airport i sat there with my
[ __ ] weed grinder and just grinded up
like a ton and and if I can compact it
so you know it's I broke the buds off
the stems right and then I would I would
fill up and put about like an 8 in each
condom whatever night nice and small I
pack it up and I would swallow like six
of them you know really don't yeah so
when you swallowed those how long did it
take the [ __ ] they're ones to come out
quick that's how boys want to come out
and I don't know like one to two days
like something like that any times you
swallow condoms every time when I went
to Thailand I give me when I went to
Russia like dad it was my [ __ ] thing
I was like that was your thing what's
[ __ ] out your pot that you would
smoke yeah when you lit it didn't ever
smell like a condom that's a
psychological issue it's not like
physical addiction is what we're talking
about the alcohol to the point like
alcohol is one of the most dangerous
physical addictions because when when
you get off of it you die from it
like that's how Amy Winehouse died like
a lot of people think she died from
drugs she actually died because she went
cold turkey off of alcohol I believe
that yeah it can I know that I'm
true drug addict is that I watched that
documentary Amy yeah and as I walked out
of the [ __ ] theater I was like [ __ ]
man I want to get that was the least
glamorous portrayal of drug addiction
ever and it just looked great to me I
was like oh my god [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]